in this short tutorial you will learn
what a shopping cart analysis
or a campaign analysis is
and how you can easily
calculate it online and with that
we would say start let's say you
have set up your
own online shop for clothing then the goal
is now  that you
want to achieve the highest possible turnover with this shop
so that you achieve the highest possible turnover
you naturally want everyone
to buy as much as possible for one
reason one way to motivate the customer to buy more products is to
suggest other products to him
the big question is which product
Strongly I am the best before the customer and this
is where the shopping cart analysis
game comes in. What does the shopping cart analysis do? The shopping
cart analysis gives you an
answer to the question of how
likely it is that a customer will buy a product if they
already have products in their shopping cart.
The shopping cart analysis gives you  so an
answer to which product
or goods
are often bought together,
so if a customer already has pants
and shoes in the shopping cart, how
likely is it that the customer
then also bought a shirt, socks or a t-
shirt, but what do I need to
be able to calculate
a shopping cart analysis for you to do a shopping cart analysis  to
calculate you need a list of
past purchases where you can see
which product was purchased together in one
purchase so you have
listed the respective products and each
row is a transaction
or purchase let's
look at an example let's say this
is yours  example data you have the
products denim shirt t shirt and shoes
each row is a transaction
or purchase 1 means
bought 0 means not bought the
first person bought denim shirt and
shoes if you use data for the
calculation alternatively
your data can also be in this form
present so each row is a
transa  ction and the purchased products
are simply separated by a comma
so that we have results that
we can interpret we
now calculate a shopping cart analysis with
data tab for this data for this
we go to data deaf.de the link finds
a video description and we copy it
our data in this
table are of course very few
cases as an example it should be enough
then click on plus and on the
tab association analysis we
simply click on all products now we
can specify the minimum support and
the minimum conference what support and
competence exactly  means let's go straight
through here below you get
the table of results and under the table you get the
interpretation of the first row but
that's exactly what we're going
through step by step now that's lhs lhs frequency
support conference and water points lift
for this data has us  data tab these
association rules a  given each
row in this table is an
association rule what these mean
let's look at the first
row now the rules for us
are in the form will the products be present
under last time in a
transaction then the products will be
under tab time  also available with a certain
probability
the frequency tells us how
often the products and the last time and
tabs occur in a
transaction in our case, i.e. how
often do shirt and shoes come before in a
transaction, so let’s just go
through how many transactions both
occur in  1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so the
frequency is 8 in eight transactions a
shirt and shoes come before the support tells
us what percentage of all
transactions that is or, to put it another way,
how likely it is that a shirt and
shoes will appear in a
transaction  let's just divide the frequency
by the number of all transactions 19
transaction ha  so
overall we get eight divided by 19 which is equal to
0.42 so the
probability of the shirt and shoes appearing
in a transaction is 42
percent the conference now tells us if
the products under recent appear in an
order how likely
it is then  also the products under
tab pages there are for our
example this means how likely
is it that if there is a shirt in the shopping
cart then there are also shoes in the shopping cart sender
this we can calculate by dividing the
frequency of shirt and shoes by the
frequency of shirt and
finally  the lift the lift indicates the
factor by which the
probability of the purchase and the
products under the time tab increases if
the products and have
already been bought recently or
in the shopping cart center in our
example, i.e. if the shirt product is in the
shopping cart  is 1.27 times
more likely to buy
shoes than if the pro  duct shirt is not
in the shopping cart if you
need support with the shopping cart analysis or
you need an individual solution
just get in touch with us we
can certainly help you and
finally a critical comment
on the choice analysis we say in the
shopping cart analysis it comes out that if
a person buys a pair of pants and shoes,
the probability is high that
this person will then also buy a shirt,
now you suggest a customer who buys
a pair of pants and shoes,
this of course also increases
the probability that
one shirt will be bought under these conditions and
another  shopping cart analysis would of
course be distorted by this
I hope you liked the video and
we'll see you next time